I'm pessimistic about whether the
plumber is going to come and but
optimistic i think in general i'm not
sure it has to do about the world though
I think it has to do with things are
going to probably be okay but it's sort
of personal or has to do with my family
and things not not I don't really think
usually in terms of the whole world
don't have to worry about themselves I
don't know I've never known when ages
start and end for instance it's the
beginning of that age there were no
airplanes the airplane was invented what
in 19 10 or 11 or when it when did the
Wright brothers or whoever did it so I
don't know what an age is I certainly in
America I think I think they're material
goods sort of dominates this era at
least this period right now it's hard
for me to think in more than a decade
you